yeah it's already yeah i didn't even realize hello hello
we're live sorry i didn't realize the youtube broadcast was
behind i i think mine's two mine's 40 seconds left yeah me
too my says my says 16 seconds i was just like i was looking
at chat and they were like whoa she's late and i was like
what you mean it says two minutes and i look at the clock it
was like it was like uh 2 p.m and And I was like, oh, shit.
It's 2 p.m.
right now.
We're professional.
All right, it's fine.
We might be.
I'm in the trailer right now, man.
You gotta fast forward it.
I'm literally in the trailer.
All right, Rose.
It's not playing.
It's sound.
I sense suffering here, spirit.
All right, I don't want to rep- I'll tell you what you're
saying so you can sync up.
Ember Lab.
Yeah, I think I try.
Oh, it's the trailer started now.
Yeah.
And then there's a lady looking at her hand and then like
And and then she has a staff It's not cold.
It's not cold.
Okay, I'm gonna do a 1080p And then the staff is glowing.
Are you there?
Yeah, no, um, no, oh my god.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
I have to fast forward.
Okay.
Oh, wait up computer.
Okay, okay, okay fast-forwarding it because I set a 1080 and
they reset me back.
Okay, it's okay, we're getting there.
We're figuring it out.
She's holding a statue now.
And then there's like a fox that has a green tail.
And then...
What the fuck is this game?
What avatar is this?
Yeah, yeah.
This is Korra.
I mean...
Oh, she has like a spirit mask.
spirit guides here once used alchemy to cleanse corruption
how am i not at the i'm still fast forward i'm not even at
the end of this fast forward i don't know and she's going so
oh there we go i made it i made it to the end it looks very
like shadow colossus colossus colossus e oh like that yeah
yeah yeah with the little colossus running around why do all
protagonists have dead parents it feels so disney-like now
how it's like if you want to be a main character you had to
have a have to have a dead mom or a dead dad or both or both
yeah
turn on bluetooth all right sound guys let me know if any
everything is okay and for Sound editing to message me on
Discord.
Also, Mint's on her phone.
That's why she sounds like this.
Yeah, sorry.
I'm on my phone.
Why does it look like an Overwatch character?
Oh, she does.
It's like an Overwatch style.
Yeah.
She does.
She looks like Onrun.
That's the newest character.
She's like a fire lady.
Kana, Scarza, Cosmora.
amazing response to canon bridges spirits in 2021 the team
was excited to take on the challenge of creating something
even bigger and better this time around our partnership with
playstation studios has empowered us to expand our scope
while still staying true to what made the first game special
since her oh wait this is a sequel i do not remember this
game once again gina gina k-e-e-n-a i've never heard of that
game before have you on this adventure canada discovers i
don't think so a video volume okay don't worry i got you
guys passed away with playstation studio support we're
building on everything that fans loved about the first game
deeper apparently the first game was really good epic boss
you know was an astro bot you should know this man you
played astro but and of course our charming spirit i can't
remember every bot not a real fan leases on playstation if
you're a real fan name every bot thanks so much for watching
and enjoy the rest of the show.
I truly was just thinking earlier clear that it needed a
Metal Gear Astrobot to only Metal Gear.
It's just Metal Gear.
Alright.
Kina.
Was Kina like a PlayStation exclusive?
I've never heard of this game before.
Piersa has been fun.
It's a fun game.
Oh, PlayStation Studios.
Kina.
Sucker Punch.
Still behind.
sorry guys oh yeah you can fast forward it and subjugated
it's yeah my phone
bloodboard is this bloodboard too
sucker punch oh you're so behind you're
online co-op
the future
wow if you were saying online co-op yo oh you're so much
choose between five characters that you're like online co-op
oh ghost of yote yo oh my god apex legends like It's just
going...
You'll understand.
You'll be there.
I can't wait to find out.
Oh, Kojima Productions!
Oh, you're missing out!
Oh, you're missing out right now!
No way.
Oh my god!
New Metal Gear?
Shut up.
Just standing.
You liar.
Let's get out there.
Oh my god, dual sense controller support.
Wait, they added Snake?
I learned how to skip forward.
Snake has always been nice.
You know, they added Snake in here.
Wait, what do you see right now?
I want to make sure I'm on time.
It's at the end.
Snake just appears in the end.
What do you mean?
I'm watching Tron actually.
what's that metal gear reference i'm mike booge from bad
robot games the game director of for loop yeah there's metal
gear racks right there has always been to make game
experiences that offer interesting surprises and
unpredictable moments that never get old the result is for
loop an emergent challenging four-player combat sandbox
really that's what you get for being in the past Wait, wait,
this phone has like 2x, doesn't it?
Which combines alien technology and humans' ability to plot
your best path.
I think I'm current now.
Do you see...
You don't see...
It's a flowchart.
I see a flowchart.
Do you see a flowchart?
Everyone votes to change the next mission.
Yeah.
Once you've chosen a node...
See his spaceship getting blown up.
Oh yeah, you're behind.
You're still behind.
I'm still in the future.
Resources or even rescue survivors that can offer cool
upgrades for your gear, all while trying to avoid the
illegal This feels very arc-free.
Yeah, I thought 5G was the future.
We've worked hard to ensure that there are tons of items to
choose from.
Sorry, I meant a skill tree.
Like, you know what?
So, Doki, I'm watching this with a hound.
You have hounds, hounds, hounds.
What the fuck is going on?
It's with teleporting anyone who touches it.
My favorite part is that you're just cutting in and out ever
so often.
All the various enemies, weapons, items, and mission
objectives.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry, guys, I'm on my phone.
Dynamic ways that create emergent gameplay and endless
replayable.
Yeah, she's getting ready for her.
Yeah, you can't miss out.
This is the most highly anticipated state of play in the
last two months.
Yeah, they're gonna talk about Metal Gear and also about
Bloodborne 2.
You can't miss out.
Oh, yeah, Devil May Cry 6.
And if you do die, don't work.
So long as one of you makes it back.
Yeah, Devil May Cry 6 is gonna be announced.
Yeah, guys, trust, trust.
The home base is a place for your team to readjust their
strategy we're gonna get that now i saw a flowchart yeah
sorry i missed skill tree each active probability map
culminates in one of multiple boss battles this is the
scanner boss this looks very arc reader's like scans for
flux deposits to harvest it feels like he was bones i don't
even remember where you're at right now i see a giant cube
in the sky rotates like a 3d puzzle you want to spread out
and attack it from all sides.
Oh, I'm looking at a giant cube.
Oh, just seeing the cube and laser grids.
I think I'm too stupid for that kind of puzzling.
Yeah, I know me too.
Where every run has you yelling and laughing and saying, I
can't believe that just happened.
We're currently in pre-beta, so there's still plenty of
polish to come.
And we need players like you to join us in upcoming play
tests.
Praise the cube.
Your feedback will be invaluable in helping us make this
game truly great.
We can't wait for you to play it for yourselves.
now bald i bet this better be free to save the world because
it feels like this game might this server might close down
in like three months like for a loop oh yeah that sounds
very extraction shooter like okay apparently you're 10
seconds behind now you're getting there man you're almost
there oh it's this game almost there yeah yeah i think if
you fast forward like one more time we'll be synced up you
really can make everything with luna fill a loop looks a bit
like new york is that a place on earth i don't know i don't
think my oh it's the it's not yeah it's a little kid looks
so cute yeah i haven't seen it feels like an escort it feels
like escort mission the game though like the what's that
game with the zombies and the guy who's like the worst yeah
zombies and the guy who takes a camera yeah who takes
pictures Dead Rising, yeah.
Where it's basically Esport Mission the game.
It's literally my worst nightmare.
And now it's your turn.
She's like a little sister.
I heard you're playing Bioshock right now.
So it's like a little sister.
Yeah.
I like, wait, have you played?
Yeah, I played all of the Bioshocks on stream.
It's really good.
Like, I think...
Did you, I bet...
Did you spare the sisters or did you to kill them.
I'm fucking course not.
Of course I killed them.
Wait, did I?
No, no.
We actually, I wanted to kill them and then my chat bribed
me to keep them alive because they wanted the good ending
because they're cowards.
Oh, cowards.
Yeah, I made a pull.
I made a pull.
I wanted to kill them for loot and then I made a pull and
got bribed to keep them alive.
Six survivors of Raccoon City are all dead from the same
thing.
Yeah, that's not good.
Oh, is that Resident Evil 9?
Oh my god, Leon.
The Rhodes Hill Chronic Care Center.
Yeah.
Are you at Resident Evil now?
Um, I think so.
Yeah.
He's like pulling up in his car.
Holy shit.
Oh, yeah.
I saw that monster.
I did, I went to, I went to New York.
Uh, I did like a demo for the Resident Evil 9.
And the monsters are like, it feels very...
It's very scary when you're playing as a girl.
You...
Leon's infected?
Leon got molded!
Yeah, he got... He has the mold!
He has the mold!
A former T-virus researcher.
No, I don't believe it.
Look at this hand!
The mold got him!
See this is what happens when you still live in your fucking
black mold apartment.
The mold's gonna get you.
That's not zombie mold.
That's black mold.
But you don't know.
It could mutate.
It could mutate like the last of us.
It could become the patient's hero.
Oh my god.
Imagine if Resident Evil 9 was
Oh.
You evil.
That'd be crazy.
Leona's plant zombie.
Wait, where is Ada?
Well, you're right.
It's been a while since you've been back there.
She's with me.
We- They're on a break right now.
She's exploring her options.
Damn.
February 27th?
Wait, that's so soon.
I didn't even realize.
I'm Sean Benson.
And I'm Sid Schumann.
When was it?
February 27th is coming out.
But before we wait, that is true.
Yeah, no, wait, Ada's older than Leon Both are coming soon
to PS5 with support.
Yeah, I play yeah Now what she's older than him now with an
announcement for fans of legacy of Kane 2003's legacy of
Kane defiance is remastered would it work by screen share it
and will be available to play order today the chapter in the
soul reaver saga maybe but it's okay so i'm i'm chilling i'm
five of them and his betrayed lieutenant where does that oh
this game this is a remaster updated hd graphics a new third
person camera and wayfinding level maps as well as bonus
features legacy of k now what do you have to tell me lost
levels deep lore photo mode have you ever played this game
this game such good voice acting demo of dark prophecy the
unreleased sequel to defiance yeah we keep the same wait you
actually played this game whether to rule a corrupt oh a
little i don't think i finished pack tuber for real please
believe i never heard of this game before legacy of pain
defiance remastered launches next yeah real gamer here i'm
actually the fake gamer No
Wait blood point Brigham Dean abyss is the latest
installment is blood boy Brigham Dean series which dates
back to No, it's legacy of king No guys, I'm just trying to
try to fuck with me right now because I'm in the future guys
Legacy of the anime now Yeah.
Just making shit up.
Is this Bloodboard?
This is like anti-bloodboard.
They have RPG Tactics Bloodboard?
I can't believe they've made Bloodboard.
It only launches this year.
And you can wishlist it starting to do.
Yeah, they went with a totally new direction.
Blu-ray 2, right?
It felt like that's what gamers really wanted from
Bloodborne and RPG tactics.
An anime girl.
Yeah, an anime girl.
That's what we were missing.
That's why it took so long for Bloodborne 2 to come out,
guys.
They had to, they had to like redo the entire concept.
Wait, is that the...
Yeah, there were some intercourse.
Oh my god, that's the Polyball!
That's the Beach Girl game!
I'm not fading.
I'm not fading man.
I'm not remember the beach girl games, but like now it's
actually but it's like this is the main series though
But like the unfun version of dead or alive You know I've
always wondered not the last half not the actual game
Fine, they're still they're still hot
I'm really upset that Dead or Alive is not, you cannot get
Dead or the main series games of Dead or Alive on American
Steam.
You can?
You can't.
You have to like buy it from the Asia Steam store or like
get a physical copy somewhere.
Oh.
Yeah, you can't actually play Dead or Alive like the good
version.
Oh no!
At least they're still sexy.
At least they're still dead or alive.
Which one?
Prodinger's fighting game, dead or alive.
Oh?
Oh hey!
Ninja!
Oh, it's the 30th anniversary.
That's why they're bringing it back.
Dead or Alive series, the latest episode, Dead or Alive,
though.
Wait,
Dead or Alive 7?
When will they give us more beach episode, Dead or Alive,
though?
That's the real content.
Yeah, give us the volleyball.
Give us the butt wrestling.
You know the butt wrestling?
We try to wrestle someone with our butt?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's what it's called, right?
No one should have survived that.
Oh, it's...
Keijo, yeah, yeah, yeah, Keijo.
I fucking love Keijo.
I used to watch, there was an anime based off of Keijo.
The game-changing sequel to Control.
What you are seeing here is an early mission captured from
our in-development.
and build i have you ever watched the anime series based off
of keijo in the version of manhattan no no i haven't but i
know it yeah i i watched the entire anime and like there's a
move called ass of babylon where like she summons like
hundreds of asses for their power and like i know it i can't
watch this trailer i'm playing control soon oh it's um it's
sort of of like i think you're fine like you're not gonna
get spoiled there are a lot of different ones you can
discover i remember i started control a long time ago i
never finished it though there's a lot of reading oh is
there there's a it's like it's more i personally felt it was
it was definitely more complicated than alan wake in terms
of like it it's like um the scp files basically yeah yeah
it's there it's literally like like their own everything
their own version of the scp whoa not i'll just have chat
explain everything to me yeah no big deal at chat explain
thanks um yeah at chat please summarize the documents for me
please some please explain this game like it's uh like it's
apex where's alan wake he's in the lake i messed up john
wick and alan wake again the other day i'm so mad at myself
i mean they sort of do look the same they have the same
beard they have like the same beard and build oh if you have
the alan uh did you get do you have the alan wake games on
steam or On Epic.
Resonance are the dominant threat.
You get a free Alan Wake skin in Fortnite.
We can't wait to share it with you later.
Do you get to?
Yeah, yeah.
So you can be Alan Wake in Fortnite.
I need to put the Alan Wake next to the John Wick skin.
Wait, we're the John Wick, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, but it's too late to get John Wick skin.
It's all, I don't know if it comes back from the store.
Wait, don't bring him back.
I don't know.
They bring it back.
I know they brought back Among Us.
I was too late to grab it though but they always bring it
back save the age of man oh yeah it rotates in half human
half angel John Wick will come back you soon yeah John Wick
will come back in doomsday is that
blood boy there's blood in it guys It's the day!
It's a plump boy too?
Plump boy.
This feels good tonight.
Oh, there's co-op.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
Bum, bum, bum.
Bum!
I like the soundtrack for this.
It's Duneborn!
Boomborn.
Yeah, this feels Doom and Bloodborne-ish.
Crimson Moon.
Coming 2026.
Ooh.
It's his period.
Oh shit.
Monster Hunter?
What is this?
Oh, yeah!
I forgot about that.
Yeah, Game Freak is finally making a new game that's not
Pokemon.
Did you hear about that?
I did, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
And people were like, why doesn't my Pokemon look like this?
Because it's actually, and like, it's gonna be...
I mean, it's a valid question.
Like, you remember how like the newest Pokemon game, the big
ass city is all like, one 3d file or some shit did you see
that tweet no yeah so like the that's that big city in the
newest pokemon game is just all one one giant model and
people were like what the fuck
oh it was fake oh my god people lying on the internet i
can't believe it yeah you fell for it i can't Oh, it's all
coming with the people.
That's cute.
I think it's also because like Pokemon has to come, like new
Pokemon games have to come out every one to two years.
Well, they're pushing those out.
Yeah, they're pushing out really fast.
I think this, apparently this game took a long time in
development.
Thanks to Fictions and Game Freak for that new look at
characters and content.
in beast of reincarnation it's coming to ps5 this summer it
looks really good i'm surprised it's not coming on the
switch three decades ago alongside the original playstation
and it introduced the world to an iconic character let them
rest let them rest digital eclipse celebrate that legacy
with rayman 30th anniversary edition rayman museum features
i've seen this guy in so long
the 1995 playstation released enhanced with new
accessibility i can smell it devil may cry is next discover
the secrets behind yeah and then after devil may cry it's
gonna be bloodborne too restored for the first time yeah for
real this is a state of play yeah they did say this would be
the biggest day of play ever insights from the original
creators yeah yeah and then after bloodboard 2 they're going
to do a remaster of mel gear solid wood and then after that
we're going to see kingdom They're leaving it all at the
last 30 minutes.
Trust us, guys.
And then the final game will be indie horror game of
Steamboat Willie.
Take control of...
Yeah, Disney is coming in with a new horror game.
No, he's public licensed now.
That's true.
I'm pretty sure they did make an indie horror game.
game of Steamboat Willie.
I'm pretty sure I saw one.
I saw it too.
Yeah, I saw a trailer.
Release date is on the horizon.
Isn't this from the people from Hollow Knight?
You know the Hollow Knight?
That's why Hollow's in the game name.
Saw.
Or not Hollow's Shovel Knight.
With Shovel Knight.
Sorry.
I bet Shovel Knight the Knights all played together.
Wolf Cub Neva first match.
Looks like Legend of Zelda.
Oh.
Alba must earn the young like the original the last
announcement will be expedition 33 together they will face
new enemies don't say that because it might happen while
confronting a monstrous world premiere if we don't think 33
anything in this i'll be shocked because and the winner it
looks sad launches february 19th no um actually man it's
gonna be expedition Up next, a tactical stealth action title
from Shueisha Games and Acquire.
They're off to find dating back to the Tenchu series.
All the porn on the internet.
Expedition 34.
Yakko, Shinobi.
It counts down, so it'd be Expedition 32.
where what number did they start with like why who counts
down i did hear that yeah
a hundred oh my okay so your planet so actually is actually
the prequel expedition 34.
what is this yeah yanko oh yako yeah oh it's a stealth game
Oh, uh-oh.
Jesus.
Tenchu?
That's the game.
It's like a top-down stealth game.
Yeah, it's kind of freaky.
Yakko.
Shinobi ops.
Yeah.
It really is like, wow.
Yeah, it's like someone says metal gear but with ninjas
that's for you yeah yeah literally metal gear metal gear has
ninjas shut up guys they plan and what's this unclaimed
novel series the bird that drinks tears um well i never
heard of this game never heard of that book before so is it
really a claim of the goddess you filthy creatures i don't
think you do Um, I used to read, okay?
I read Pretty Little Liars before it was a TV show.
This world was never yours to keep.
Pretty Little Liars.
So who was A?
Oh, it was the girl that died.
Spoiler alert, by the way.
She's like, fake her dad.
Crazy work.
Alright, that's just...
from Crapton?
Isn't that fuck, what game did they make?
Is that the gotcha game company?
Who?
Crapton.
Why is that a chicken?
We're gonna see a chicken man.
Oh, no, I see him.
I see him.
He's huge.
Yeah.
He's a lot of chicken.
Oh, dang.
What the Okay, cool.
Bluff chicken.
This is just Warriors game.
I get to be a chicken man!
KFP looking real buff lately.
The one that escaped.
He escaped the factory.
I mean, it's unique at least.
You know what?
I'll give him that.
Chicken boy.
It's cool.
Chicken, chicken board.
Yes, chicken board.
But there's so many enemies.
That's, that's, that's war.
Oh yeah, you're right.
Yeah, it feels, but it's, I feel like this is all like
pre-rendered though.
I don't know.
Wait, no, actually, that's gameplay, right?
Yeah.
Because I can't tell it's pre-rendered or gameplay.
Usually it says, right?
They'll say like, this is pre-rendered footage, right?
It would say, no, usually it would say this one is captured
on the PS5, but then it didn't say that.
Yeah, you're right.
Yeah, so then I'm like, this feels all pre-rendered.
So I don't know if that's actual gameplay.
You're right.
Because the other ones was like captured on the PS5.
Oh, Lucasfilm?
Yeah, see pre-alpha in-game capture on PS5.
Welcome to the Galactic League.
Oh, I am still behind.
Yeah.
Why not take part in a friendly exhibition race?
Wait, is this part racing?
Oh, my God.
I saw, I remember I saw this trailer.
in the game awards.
Oh, wait, this is Star Wars?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Pod Racing.
Wait, are you watching the YouTube or the Twitch?
YouTube?
You should watch the Twitch.
I don't know if you'll buffer on the Twitch, though, but the
Twitch was always, like, synced up.
Okay, I don't know if I have the Twitch app when you do.
Oh, yeah.
I'm looking forward to now the Pod Racing.
God racing.
Is this blood point in space?
If they weren't holding me back right now, I have you frozen
in carbonate.
Guys, next up is Devil May Cry 6, guys.
We're real.
They're saving it all on the last 15 minutes.
Blast.
Wait, how do I watch it?
What's it called?
Or who's hosting?
Oh, it's Stata Play.
Play Satan?
Yeah, or Stata Play.
they okay
I see it looks good though pod the pod racing here pod
racing oh James five immature and reckless he's a bad
influence on the other I'm buffering oh there we go are you
James five look I know where this is yeah yeah yeah see
we're synced up we're finally synced up it only took us 35
minutes we did it you what I know all about your exploits in
Iceland.
I strongly believe that there is a need for such heart and
intuition in modern spycraft.
I have a feeling this is not Idris' elbow.
I need I state the obvious.
He is not ready.
James, the service is over.
You're a rare breed.
Are they still in England?
I mean, I hope so.
There was a UK flag, I saw it, I saw it.
I was gonna say, I hope the agency is still based in the
United Kingdom.
Housekeeping, I presume.
You seem the kind of guy who knows what he likes.
So you won't do anything stupid.
Agents are very sure.
And there's still ladies in there.
Of course, there's always bond girls.
What if there's like a...
cult we will deny i know what if there's like a sleeping
with the ladies minigame oh like a honey pot mission this
looks like oh my gosh yeah yeah yeah it feels very like
hitmaness it's all there
first oh i spy the hitman devs oh that's why apparently spy
the hitman devs That's why it looks very good, buddy.
That explains it.
I manage the game content team within third-party portfolio.
We evaluate games coming from publishers all over the world
from Indie to AAA.
Those of us in the third-party portfolio team travel the
world and meet with our partners.
And it's even more exciting for me when those partners have
been foundational to my own love of videos.
Guys, this is it.
Devil May Cry 6 right here.
Konami is definitely the most famous.
Okay, actually, that's...
A lot of people remember Konami for being with PlayStation
in the very beginning.
Wait, what is Konami?
Oh, there's...
them with new technology and new ways of designing video
games that we haven't thought of before we were really
impressed when kanami approached us with their list of
announcements for today's so mark the occasion we wanted to
try something a little bit better join you today from kanami
creative front tokyo bay not only to show us some really
exciting reveals oh my gosh also spotlight some of the key
talent behind it we're really excited about the diverse
lineup they've brought today and we hope you will be here
enjoy do you guys like my mint soundboard right now, guys.
My mint set.
Mint?
You're...
No.
Oh, no!
Please take the command of this immense army.
It is now preparing to unleash an insurrection.
It's diving!
Liquid's goal is to seize control of SRP.
The sons of the patient.
treat system that controls the soldier we lost it will you
do this for me will you terminate liquid how long is my body
gonna hold out when all of this is over you'll have no
choice but to accept yeah are you are you kidding me yeah so
began the war between zero and big boss.
Do you understand, Snake?
Any means necessary.
Just stop liquids and are you crying?
Guns off the page.
Because I knew where my loyalty belong.
Nukes.
They're bringing nukes into Costa Rica.
We are not allowed to bear arms.
What are they saying, Doki?
Tell me everything.
I can't hear anything.
I forgot you have no volume.
She has no audio, by the way.
While she's watching this.
Yes.
Over and over and over.
Yeah, I'll just repeat the last for you.
Is that you?
Answer me!
Boss!
My god!
What are you saying?
I'm just repeating the lines!
Tell me what you're saying!
Oh my god, the peace walker!
I'm so happy.
Actually happened.
Oh my god, it was Metal Gear.
Oh my god, wait, the Metal Gear...
Oh yeah, yeah, we're definitely gonna get Metal Gear solid
remastered yeah they did actually i see that means wait is
it only those two games yeah yeah wait they only they didn't
wait no it can't be those two games oh three games they said
three games see guys now after this now after this there'll
be double may cry six and then bloodborne two and then
kingdom hearts four we went backwards remember when we said
Oh, Apple!
Wow, RIP Acid, RIP Metal Gear Acid.
Let me go on there.
For your patience!
Title!
Metal Gear Solid Master Collection Volume 1 will be the
final update of the update.
Station 5!
Wait, Peace Walker is Koa?
Yeah, it's Koa.
Oh!
Oh,
there's a higher resolution for the metal.
Oh my god, I'm so happy.
I just finished the game.
What do you mean?
You mean wasn't high res already?
You did it.
Peace Walker.
Yeah, no, they said the Snake Eater.
That's special sale!
I bought full price for this game!
Now it's on...
Yeah, it's on sale right now.
Oh my god.
I could have waited.
And a higher resolution?
The hell?
Oh my god, the updates.
Let's go.
I literally just finished the game and then they fucking
said 50% off.
They did it!
I can't believe... Oh my god, also I...
I can't believe they actually like...
Or did that horror they did what they said was impossible to
do they did it What's that remember all of this?
Yeah, yeah, seeing all of this.
Yeah, I understand that middle gear reference Oh, you're you
do.
Oh, what's the next video?
Listen.
Wait, what is this?
Wait, I'm still behind?
What what is this?
What am I looking at?
A triple to a snake from an octopus Darwin practical octopus
Oh, this is the game.
Okay, so Konami was like putting out this game and it looked
literally like Metal Gear, but if it was an octopus.
And so I guess they're doing a collab now.
Decoy octopus.
Wait, he has ears.
So cute, though.
Wait, does that look like fun?
The graphics are insane.
I know they look so good for like a joke it looks like a
joke game Like a parody game.
Yeah, no, there was like it was like a real game And now I
guess they have like an official Metal Gear thing.
Yeah, that's fine What the heck what the fuck Darwin's
paradox play the demo tomorrow?
I wonder what's a sequel then yeah, oh Castlevania No way.
Yeah.
40th anniversary is this year, apparently.
Go on the octopus.
Hold on.
Don't spoil it.
You think attacked by rats, okay?
Are you back on the YouTube video?
Yeah, I had to.
Yeah, I was.
Because Metal Gear was happening.
Castlevania 40th.
Wait, this is not happening, isn't it?
No, no, no.
It's a new game.
Oh, looks really good.
Does look good.
Yeah, it's like the same gameplay style, but just with new,
better graphics.
Yeah, give me my whip, baby.
Like size throw there.
Oh, okay, that bomb.
Yeah, let's get it.
We're gonna get to the boss decides and it actually looks
really sick.
I'm excited.
I mean, the anime is also pretty good.
Not the newest season.
You know, you guys would, if you guys ever watched the
newest season of Castlevania, it's pretty ass.
Oh no!
Oh, it's by the devs of Dead, uh, Dead Cells.
Aww.
Yeah, it looks good.
Thank you, Konami, for bringing back.
They're finally using their IPs again.
Oh, my God.
There's so many new well-mocking premieres.
No more Pachinko.
They're taking a break from Pachinko, guys.
What'd you say?
They're finally taking a break from Pachinko.
I know.
We won.
Gamers rise up.
Your voice matters.
Series.
Alright, next is Devil May Cry.
But Konami have a moment.
Devil May Cry.
Yeah.
But Konami have a moment.
I love this comment.
It's almost like, Konami.
Konami needs to make more games so they can make more
Pachinko machines.
They're right out of IPs.
They'll release another Metal Gear patchy slot.
Simon doesn't do me.
What's this?
You can't stay in this room forever.
Is this Devil May Cry 6?
I can't stay in this room forever.
It is.
Silent Hill?
No, it's Castle.
It's going to be hard.
Oh, hell.
Wait, I wonder if the Bluebird team game...
Oh, wait.
When does that get announced?
I'll remember.
It was announced in Game Awards.
Oh, it is Silent Hill.
Come back to Silent Hill.
Did you just say come back to Silent Hill?
I don't know.
I don't have sound.
Oh, yeah.
You just see a radio.
You're just like, why did he pick up the radio?
I woke up in the water again.
No, this is Left 4 Dead.
I don't know.
But this time it's...
Well, it's pretty foggy.
I think it's Silent Hill.
St. Amelia?
That's not Silent Hill.
Foggy, of course it is.
It's the only place where fog happened.
Yeah, but it's St. Amelia.
That's a different city.
So was Silent Hill at?
happen oh saint amelia i see it now oh someone's like
rearranged the letters and it's silent hill where's the a in
silent hill what do you
silent hill the a is silent
it's salient hill The truth.
It's very Silent Hill 5-V.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, there's gonna be a scene where you're gonna be like,
What the fuck?
Oh.
I don't think I'm there yet.
The water.
Where is this?
Silent Hill Townfall.
Oh, it is Silent Hill.
They're in a new town.
The new hill?
Sound like it was spreading, I guess.
Yeah, it's a mindset.
Oh my god, another Konami game?
Wait, seriously?
Yeah, yeah, there's so many IPs!
Holy fuck!
This is like the Konami of Konami play.
Not Seda plays, Konami of play.
Seda Konami.
Devil may cry.
Yeah, so that they can make a party slot.
Konami bought the IP of Double May Cry.
The state of Konami.
The world is shrouded by light fall.
I wonder if it's a new...
Konami doing videos that aren't Yu-Gi-Oh!
This is the new Yu-Gi-Oh game.
Trust.
It might be.
New Yu-Gi-Oh!
Spin, spin up.
I refuse to accept an ending like this.
Oh, Code Vane.
Oh my god.
Kingdom Hearts rocks us.
Konami fought the Kingdom Hearts IP.
Oh, I'm buffering now too.
What?
Is this a...
Is this new?
No, it's Code Vane, apparently.
Come on.
Oh, again.
Oh wait, Code Vane?
Yeah.
There's a new RPG game.
Expedition 33 anime edition.
Oh my god, the anime reskin.
Those were her majesty's words.
Oh, it's not Cobain?
Wait, what is it?
It's stop the light fall.
Dot hack.
I don't know anything about... I don't know anything about
RPG, JRPGs.
Rev is... No, no, it's Rev Noir.
Rev Noir.
What is Rev Noir?
Is that new IP?
Oh, new IP.
Okay, see?
New pachinko game.
See you guys.
Reb Noir.
When the hoax sparks catastrophe, I think Devil May Cry
might be last.
Yeah, I think so too.
They always say it's the best game for this.
Yeah, in the last...
Imagine it's Bloodborne 2 and Devil May Cry.
In the last nine minutes, it's like Bloodborne 2 Devil May
Cry.
Kingdom Hearts 4.
Kingdom Hearts 4, yeah.
Last nine minutes, trust guys.
I got the Metal Gear one right.
Well, it's funny because like people predicted Metal Gear
because all of the Metal Gear games went on sale like
yesterday oh really oh that's weird yeah that's suspicious
yeah everyone was like okay oh something's happening at that
state of no more konami stuff that's a lot of games that
konami announced at once i know yeah oh i like the stage
they're all like presenting them thanks konami what is this
master cool A man with your skills Batman must be able to
move Unconstrued Batman Oh, I see it now John Wick Wait, no,
it's John Wick Wait Wait a minute Oh my god, it is It is No,
it's not What the fuck
We're just talking about John Wick.
John Wick video game, so...
Oh my god, you can actually be John Wick and Alan Wick!
Stable.
Constant.
It's actually Alan Wick?
And then about three.
Yay.
Writing was too boring.
Okay.
I want to see them like walk up to each other and do the
spider-man meme
Already so oh my god, no they can't make a John Wick video
game.
I'm gonna lose my mom I think it's already too late man.
I think they're already way in.
Oh my god.
It's actually his face It's actually Keanu Reeves
It's real Keanu They got him in the video games.
That means if he dies in the game, he dies in real life.
He's canon, guys.
He's real.
Wait.
There's no way we still have four more minutes.
Or five more minutes of...
That can't be...
Is that the...
There's no way to end with Marathon after John Wick.
There's no way.
The end with an extraction.
now oh my god what's marathon it's another extraction
shooter from the people who made destiny dreams endure okay
so small among the stars breathe softly there's no way like
john wick should have been the ending trailer there's no
fucking way there has to be a trailer after marathon
you know what i'm surprised we didn't get like a marvel
thing that's true i think that they already but they
announced the wolverine game already in the in the past
state of place i feel like they're just like we don't need
to really announce it again we'll know if we get like some
pop song that's true well i won't know i can't hear it but
we're out singing the song to you I hear it.
I hear it.
We've had to do things to survive.
Things I never would have.
How do I skip to Devil May Cry?
We're all monsters.
She's already checked out of the trailer.
She's like, I've seen enough.
Embrace.
I think it's a good thing.
criminal that they put marathon right after John Wick.
Yeah.
How could they do this through the marathon?
That's the fact that they have to follow up on the John Wick
trailer.
Imagine if they didn't know what was coming.
I guess I imagine they probably don't know.
They're coming before them.
Yeah.
They're like really all confident and they're like, yeah,
our game is great.
Good.
And then the trailer like you're like oh fuck it's like no
it's that uh smiling friends like will you excuse me for one
hey everyone my name is joe ziegler and i'm the game
director on marathons today we're excited to announce our
server slam from february 26th through march 2nd where you
can join us on town server slam test marathon on playstation
5 and other platforms our server slam features an
introduction to the survival game there's no way they're
ending with this chance to explore we have three minutes
left and they're explaining it marathad right now oh no no
they're explaining the game playstation plus players we're
also excited there's one last thing we have to have the you
know the obligatory like oh yeah here's one more will
premiere i keep trying to skip ahead trying to suit the fast
forward.
Yeah.
What do you see right now?
Just so I know where I'm at.
A black screen and then Marathon coming to PS5 and PC March
5th, 2026.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm way behind.
Hey, I'm Brett.
And I'm Kristen.
Thanks to Bungie for that new look at Marathon.
They're still explaining Marathon.
It's a server slam run in February 26th.
It is.
We have three more minutes.
PlayStation Plus over the next few months.
It might be an hour plus.
No!
They're talking about the PlayStation Plus catalog network
thing.
In collaboration with Marvel Games, be greater together.
It's not like this.
Double my cry.
The Spider-Man must balance their personal and heroic
responsibilities.
Are you crying right now?
You want more and more again?
No, there might be one last.
No!
The cat and...
Not fucking Marathon Joins the PlayStation I said we got
nothing Marvel And then they showed Spider-Man The
PlayStation Plus classics catalog Welcomes two fan favorites
over the next few months Starting with Tekken Dark
Resurrection Not like this They had a choice to end on John
Wick And they chose Marathon Classic in March Please stay
psyched Don't worry Don't give us a two two minutes left The
original PlayStation version of Time Crisis explains arcade
action to the classic catalog.
Even if it's just the...
Oh, wait.
This version also offers gyro-stopping gaming using
DualShock 4 or PS5 DualSense controller simulating the
original light gun experience.
Is that pecking?
It's Time Crisis.
Oh, there's Time Crisis, too.
I love Time Crisis.
Oh, my God.
Big Walk is a cooperative multiplayer adventure about
teamwork and talking.
Oh, there they are.
about another sloppy sisters hang out and get lost with your
friends and an open world full of challenges puzzles and
playful discoveries
what the hell is this the next sloppy sisters game that's
all for me and Brett but we still have a lot more cool stuff
to show you that's us when we're playing the game April 30th
and creative director Greg Gregory Loudon has even more
systems and combat to break down.
Let's take a look.
Oh, oh, oh.
Big walk.
Okay, we have one last game that we want to tell you about.
One last trailer.
Wait, wait, wait.
We actually do have one last trailer.
Min, we do have one last trailer.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
What is it?
I know you better than that.
Oh, never mind.
I, I lied.
Hey, everyone.
I'm Gregory Loudon.
They're just explaining another game.
Today we're excited to show off our comeback stronger
features and Eclipse gameplay running on PlayStation 5.
It was the Saros game.
It's basically like Toho, but what if it's a shooter?
Who is discovering the hostile shape-shifting planet of
Karko.
I don't know if you ever played Returnal, but it's like a
spiritual successor of Returnal, and it's literally like
Toho if it's the shooter.
Oh, okay.
That sounds terrifying.
It's pretty fun.
I played Returnal.
It's really, really fun, but it's also really hard.
This looks fun, but...
You are not on your own.
But it's not Double Me Cry 6.
Interacting with the survivors of Echelon 4 will help you
understand the mysteries of Carcosa.
They didn't all die.
Some of them changed.
This is Primary, the voice of Sultari.
You can engage with our permanent progression systems to
upgrade your armor's attributes and acquire special perks.
With Carcasson modifiers, you can adjust your experience by,
for example, making hostile So it's great because I can't
hear anything, everyone just looks like they're talking in
slow motion.
However, all adjustments you choose must be kept in balance
to ensure a consistent challenge level.
Primary also allows you to teleport directly to any biome
that you have unlocked.
This means getting back into the action quicker.
It also means easier replayability the further you get into
the world.
just end with the logo of devil may cry that's it restart
the selected biome and get back to where you were and now
it's time to take another shot at what kills you the first
time around
eventually you come across an alien device yeah lord by
using it you discover that it calls the eclipse and then
eclipse happens
intense eclipse the eclipse corrupts the world it's a
complete escalation of our gameplay our audio yeah hostiles
now shoot corrupted projectiles which produce your maximum
armor integrity but you can restore it by using your power
weapon weapons and artifacts also become corrupted which
this is so much information about this game which ramps up
yeah this game is like a little i remember returnal was a
little complicated too we can't wait for you to play saros
when we launch on april 30 2026.
oh and that's where the toho starts i see it yeah yeah they
all all the attacks are literally toho
I will say the outfits are very mediocre though.
The DLC, not DLC, the exclusive outfits.
What's this?
A lot of gotten there.
Oh my god, there's more trailers.
There's actually more trailers left.
It's not just one hour.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, wait!
Oh, there is a new Marvel game.
Oh, I think this is a fighting game.
This is a fighting game?
No.
Oh, is this...
Like the one that's like really used.
yeah yeah yeah we still have to see it it's the fighting
game i hope it does better because like i don't know if you
heard about 2x ko from league you cannot stand against the
storm no but um riot games launch the fighting game um
that's also similar to this one which is like a tag teamer
tag team and then uh they recently fired majority of their
staff like a couple of days ago
Oh It magic's in there now.
I've got this one.
Oh shit Wolverine X-Men get it done Oh my god, it really
does remind me of Marvel versus Capcom
What's this magic?
She's cute.
Oh, she's in Marvel rivals.
So you're gonna see a butterfly robot danger Who the fuck is
danger?
Wait, Seed Blum?
Oh, Wolverine's voice by Seed Blum!
I didn't even notice.
Surrender to avoid further danger.
Oh.
That suits him.
Yeah.
He was also starring the screen.
Yeah, I was like, who's...
Who's she?
Yeah, Seed...
Oh, Seed Blum was voiced Wolverine 20 years ago.
I didn't even know this.
I didn't realize that.
Oh my god, Cosmo and Howard the Duck.
He's also in it.
What the hell?
What is...
What is this?
What is the most I've ever known about Marvel.
I bet you know all about Marvel now because of Marvel
rivals.
I did, honestly.
It's the most I've ever known about Marvel.
Magic actually looks really...
It looks very faithful.
I'm going to look at Dord...
Dash, so tell me when the next trailer comes up.
You're already like skipper, skipper.
She's doing the...
She's trained the X-Men over years through battle
simulation.
So as a zoner in this game, she's going to set up so much
many traps that our opponents are going to feel like they're
running i have no idea who danger is guys is she like a
popular character or is that a niche player no more though i
think it's the first time i've received it yeah she's pretty
niche marvellous fighting souls is she is the danger i mean
that's cool oh she's the a for x-men pre-order is open next
week so please check out a variety of additions and goodies
and we can't wait to share with you some more info.
Please, shake it up.
I am dangerous.
Stay tuned.
You know how they practice that.
Oh, you missed out.
You missed out on a cool line that they did.
Oh, my bad.
Aw, the two guys.
Yeah.
They're like, stay tuned.
Oh, I see them do the pose.
Yeah, actually, you said it exactly as they did.
What is this?
God of War?
Yo, I played that in like four hours.
Oh, shit.
Wait, this is God of War.
Wait, is this a remaster of God of War?
Uh, now you gotta replay.
Oh my god.
Yeah, the remaking God of War.
Okay, if they're ending with that, that's worth it.
Are you enjoying God of War?
It's actually...
It's pretty fun, but God of War like the the uh sequel god
war 2 is very long i'm at part 5 and i've only i'm only at
50 yeah but the boy i'm only at 50 and i'm already at part
5.
hey hey what's happening people it is og tc that's right the
original trilogy yeah i'm back baby oh my god they got the
original voice actors some exciting news about the series
today starting with that teaser that you just saw yeah now
look we are happy and exciting to finally confirm that uh
this one is there's no boy in this one it's just anger he's
just very angry trilogy remake is now in development the
first one yeah man i know i know i know sit down sit down
sit down yeah he basically kills it's not really a spoiler
he basically kills all the guys in his realm we get back to
share another update it took like three parts for him to do
it next time we come back we're coming with something big
baby yeah and in addition since we're approaching the last
few months of god of war's 20th anniversary i like this
guy's christmas yeah it was like the most legendary crash
out now this announcement is a passion project that was it
warranted experience god of war yeah no it was warranted
because like the gods killed his family and heartfelt
storytelling like you've never
um that's where you're getting so thank you for his first
kid is a girl and we can't wait for you to see what we've
got cooking to keep the next 20 years surprising fresh and
fun is able to play all right you can you can watch it now
just go just go to the underworld and get her back i'm back
the new kid was was a replacement kid
that's cool that's cool guys we happen so much i can't
believe they're remaking god of war i never i mean they were
eventually going to it's not even like a remaster yeah
do you think it needs a remake yeah yeah because there's no
there's no uh uh remaster on steam oh it's sort of like it's
like you can only play on playstation 3 i think spartans our
duty is to spart oh it's one of those situations yeah yeah
there's a reaction there's more trailers oh it's uh oh is
this the origin oh it's a god of war origin game but it's
like scott side scroller 2d yeah what the hell yeah i know
it's like that's like such a pivot like he looks so young
this boy of war
metroidvania god
of war Metroid So interesting God of War Oh god Oh available
today Oh shit You can play this now Oh yeah You can
literally play a different God of War game You felt like it
Wait that's how they ended Oh No that's it That's okay Um I
mean At least It's better than Marathon.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But, like, I felt like the God of Ania and then the, and
then the remixed.
The remixed.
Yeah.
I agree.
Well, we got the new Silent Hill.
Yeah, the new Silent Hill.
The new God of War.
New Metal Gear Solid Collection.
John Wick.
Yeah.
John Wick is cool.
John Wick was pretty cool.
I was like, you had Metal Gear and God of War.
Are you not happy?
I'm not happy.
We didn't have Double May Cry 6.
I'm greedy.
I was promised a Double May Cry 6, but I'll take the Metal
Gear.
You know, you're right.
You're right.
You...
We did have Metal Gear, though.
I said it as a joke and then it happened.
No, I knew it was going to happen.
Oh, yeah.
I sniffed it out.
Oh, the Steam sale.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The Steam.
Oh, I mean, Space Station 5 still has no game.
I mean, you wait like, if we just wait like two to three
months, it'll just show up on Steam anyway, I feel.
Yeah.
Nothing is ever truly PlayStation exclusive.
We just wait long enough.
Except for, yeah, even Kingdom Hearts.
Are there any games that are like, well, I guess like all
the Pokemon games are like system exclusive.
Yeah, because they're, they can, because you can really only
run it on the Switch.
I feel like it's like a lot of games that are like any
Nintendo.
Yeah, because they're like made in mind with the, uh, with
the hardware, like the special hardware.
Uh, hey, I still vouch for AstroBot.
Oh yeah, AstroBot is still a PlayStation.
exclusive well oh and bloodborne yeah i mean it has to be
well not bloodborne but like astrobot because of like it's
paying tribute to all the sony games yeah yeah yeah uh i
mean it was a pretty good state of play i felt like you know
it it gave us a lot of content yeah yeah it actually did
announce a lot of new games for it to look forward to saw a
lot of them are like coming up this year as well yeah i
didn't feel like any game really overstated to welcome yeah
like it's kind of they explained stuff and then went on to
the next thing yeah yeah i thought i'm glad that it didn't
end on marathon especially following up with john wick i
wish john wick was i mean like i mean god of war remaster
was a pretty good announcement but i think like john wick at
the end would have been pretty hyped too because like it was
such Keanu Reeves at the end.
Alan Wick would have been better.
Yeah, like, you know, it's not like, I felt like, I think, I
remember last state of play was pretty mediocre, but this
one was all right.
I don't remember what.
I liked it.
Yeah, I didn't even remember what last state of play had for
announcements.
I just remembered it was very, I just remember saying that,
oh, it felt really mediocre.
Like, didn't really have a lot of like really fun
announcements.
But this one did.
this one had a lot of fun announcements to look forward to
yeah i thought it was good uh yeah it was yeah i loved how
like the moment it went to metal gear your whole thing
crashed out what the hell this was a targeted attack to me
the perfect timing thought we might get something kingdom
hearts for You know it was like a copium.
Yeah, that was a copium.
Kingdom Hearts I feel like we gotta wait like five more
years until he's here anything about kingdom hearts 4.
Honestly.
I don't know.
I feel like for kingdom hearts.
Wait, when did kingdom hearts 3 come out?
I'm gonna look that up.
Kingdom hearts.
I don't know.
It's been a long time now.
I think I think most people aren't going to be alive.
when Kingdom Hearts finishes.
That's so sad.
Kingdom Hearts 3 was 2019.
Yeah, but Kingdom Hearts 2 was 2005.
What the fuck?
Okay, Kingdom Hearts 1 was 2002.
Kingdom Hearts 2 was 2005.
And then 3 was 2019.
What the fuck happened?
Yeah, I think we're going to wait like five to six more
years, guys, for Kingdom Hearts 4.
Yeah.
Yeah, probably.
I think they...
Well...
Maybe they're just waiting for Disney to make more IPs.
They ran out of Worlds.
They ran out of Disney IPs to make Disney Worlds.
They still have so many.
That's not even.
We're going to have...
They could bring back Dinosaur.
Okay, now that's dope.
Now that's dope, man.
I don't think a lot...
I don't think...
I feel like...
Wait, how much did Dinosaur...
as we're making a box office.
probably like zero dollars.
I don't know.
It doesn't matter.
They still have more IP.
Oh, you're right.
They never had Emperor's New Group.
Emperor's New Group was never, uh, never.
Yeah.
Juana.
There's like Enconto.
Wait, technically now Disney owns the simpsons now so this
simpsons can be canon can you imagine if you have simpsons
in the kingdom hearts universe it's like so has been your
home when we're simpsons hanging out with sora from kingdom
hearts oh yeah you have to have like sora again where you
like write on the the billboard like I won't rank Donald
Duck or something.
And then Mr. Burns is like the heartless villains or
whatever.
Yeah, Mr. Burns has the heartless.
He's working with Organization 13.
And then it works too well.
It works too.
Oh my God.
And they're family guy.
They can actually have Simpsons and family guy in Kingdom
Arts.
Oh my gosh.
There's another minigame where you sing the opening with and
there's like memes today.
And all you see is violence and movies and sex on TV.
It's their own little, like the Little Mermaid, the Little
Mermaid's rhythm game, but with Family Guy.
Oh, it's terrible.
No, it just reminds me of that time I met Sandhorn.
March, I have to go seal the door to practice
well Doki thanks for letting me crash I'm gonna go get food
now yeah I hope you have a good time good and I'm glad you
I'm glad you arrived safely oh yeah for those who are
wondering she's traveling because of the Valentine's concert
that she's that's tomorrow right yeah I have a 3D jazz
concert tomorrow Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And there's streaming tickets out right now.
I don't remember the link of it, but I think you can Google
it.
Yeah, you can just Google it.
Just Google it.
But streaming tickets are out right now.
You guys want to catch it.
If you can't travel, I think the tickets are sold out, but
they're still streaming tickets.
And so, yeah, I believe.
See you later, then.
Yeah, see him in.
Oh, yeah.
And she forgot to download OBS on her travel laptop or
travel PC.
Oh, it's actually like much worse than that.
That's okay.
Wait, what?
What do you mean?
What much worse?
Um, it's not connecting to the internet at all.
What?
Wait, what?
It also says it doesn't have Bluetooth anymore.
What the fuck happened?
Well, you tested it out before you traveled, right?
I was like, I hate Windows 11.
So I reinstalled Windows 10 and it broke everything.
Did you like reinstalled it like before you left?
like what happened yeah yeah i do oh that's like windows 10
101 never install it before you leave look a lot's going on
okay so i was like that that's kind of silly
give me a break yeah all right i'll talk to you later yeah
yeah i hope you have fun tomorrow and and have a good dinner
slash i mean brunch i guess oh we have a good dinner bye
badminton 3 p.m i don't know it's oh that is kind of lunch
yeah i was gonna say lunch dinner ish because like who gets
dinner at 3 p.m i guess you get dinner at 3 p.m no 3 p.m
okay i'm leaving all right all right bye-bye have fun bye
bye bye oh my god oh my god last robo mint to end to end the
car Sorry, the AI stopped working, guys.
Yeah, I invented a Mint AI to talk to me, so I feel less.
God, that sounded so pathetic.
Yeah, Doki finally took her meds, and the voices stopped.
I realized, the moment I said that out loud, I was like, oh,
God, that sounded so pathetic.
all right before don't worry don't leave yet i'm still i'll
still be streaming for a little bit um because i have a few
sponsors that i have to do that i talked about yesterday but
before i do i have to get water i'll be right back guys let
me grab water real quick
i'm back yeah i was very surprised about a couple of the
announcements today i was not i mean was silent hill i feel
like silent has that was silent hill announced before or
like was that new Silent Hill The newest one The Fuck Town
Fall You know what it's new Yeah I was gonna say I was like
Dude just get a Silent Hill Ready another Yeah
Yeah Yeah I remember I was like I felt like I've heard about
Another IP of Silent Hill But we never saw a trailer of it I
don't know We're like What was it, Saint Aminity?
And they're like If you rearrange Silent Hill It's spelled
out saint amenity i'm like what the you're talking about
there's no eight in silent hill
i wonder wait which uh which dev team is working on it
silent hill time town fall uh we at screen burn interactive
is being made by an indie studio screen burn have they ever
have they ever made uh this made a game before no code and
made overall observation and stories untold salient hill
patra said thank you for the bitties thank you thank you did
you know st amelia back backwards is all toekeeper thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you um also thank you all
for this uh the tier one subs and the twitch prime everyone
but everybody sorry everybody sorry we could i couldn't say
thank you to you guys while we were watching talking a
minute it was basically it had to be like the most most like
um scuffed collab we've ever had together because like she's
on her phone um the internet was a little spotty I was in
the future she was in the past so we were watching two very
different things
she she is not but most scuffed collab for now
She had no volume for her state of play.
It was communicating via Morse code at times.
But it was really fun.
It was fun baiting her being like, oh my god, Bloodborne.
Oh my god, Metal Gear.
And it ended up actually being Metal Gear.
All right, I need to know what this observation game.
So, oh, I don't know.
i've never heard of these games that they've made no code
they made observation and stories untold i mean stories
untold had pretty good reviews i've heard about this game
before i never played it myself and their internet dies on
metal gear like everything happened
but it was a very fun it was a very fun watch a lot with
with men um uh i had a great time um um both games are
pretty good do you think they'll do do you guys think that
they'll do um uh silent hill justice though i was surprised
that they didn't get uh they didn't get the the same dev
team that made silent hill too i really like the remastered
i personally really like the silent hill um two remasters so
i was surprised they didn't get them yeah i was gonna say i
was looking through the trailer it doesn't really have like
like the similar gameplay um um uh the similar gameplay as
uh silent like the the no code dev team that hasn't made a
game that's similar in gameplay to what silent hill is so um
i'm i'm very curious on how that's gonna be like uh not so
deadpoint thank you for the five gifted subs thank you thank
you one wing and banana thank you for the twitch prime thank
you thank you oh yeah they're too bit you're right they
already have their hands full with silent hill one remake i
don't think i'll be playing too was so fucking scary for me
actually um took i was so scared my like i would i could not
do more than two hours of that game every stream um what
else i think i'm obviously the one i'm looking forward to is
the god of war uh remaster it's remastered right it's not a
remake right it's not just a remastered because it's like in
development i feel like if it's in development i don't think
we're gonna see the game until i don't think we're gonna see
the full remastered yeah it's a full remake i mean they have
to it's it's the game is like incredibly old so like they'll
have to remake it from scratch um and i'm glad that they got
the original voice actor too for him um yeah but i'm
definitely looking forward to john wick the original re the
god of war remake trilogy uh because i've never played the
original trilogy before as well um and like you know the
only way to actually play is like get on the playstation 3
you know and i don't have playstation 3 um not anymore i
only have a playstation 5 i'm looking forward to those two
the most um what else and i mean they didn't oh gosh i
already forgot all the games that they announced they
announced so many things state of play um games what okay
play play play play playstation games they've announced so
far uh josh wick we have now so many new um multiplayer game
a lot of friend slop games which i was very surprised by
like you know they have co-op now for ghost of yote um i'll
definitely be streaming resident evil the fact that resident
evil is coming out this month i didn't even realize it is in
two weeks resident evil is coming out in two weeks oh the
james bond game i almost forgot the james bond
Let's see.
Dead or alive.
I'm so sad that dead of alive.
Dead or alive isn't...
I'm so sad dead or alive isn't the beach game.
The beach games aren't available on Steam for...
because it's like restricted restricted to Asia even the
English versions too I looked it up I've always wanted to
stream I've always wanted to stream the dead or alive main
game series
I've always wanted to stream the main games you know
yeah you can't get it in America I think you have you have
to have like a Asian account to get the versions like
because there is a there is like an english version for the
beach the beach game episodes the beach episodes but like
it's not um it's not accessible in na um but definitely all
of those games i'm looking forward to for sure yeah for the
plot guys for the plot um all right let's pull up let me
pull up the sponsor stuff real quick we're not doing special
event no more just chatting um let's see where is my sponsor
tab let's where is it there it is wait I have no active
sponsorship does it not start now I thought it starts now
what time does it start hey temple yes of course for the
plot of course i am a plot enjoy all right let me let me
check the time it said the 12 guys it is the 12 right now
all right oh 9 p.m never mind
12 what time toky oh 9 p.m 9 p.m look i looked at the date i
just didn't look at the time.
I made one tiny little oopsie.
Just a tiny little oopsie guys.
Or I can move you guys down here.
Just a little oopsie doopsie.
Oops.
Don't worry.
I will have time.
Surely this month to actually do it a sponsor, I believe.
Don't worry, I'm very professional.
There's no way I forget about it.
I have, like, literally two more weeks, guys, for me to do
that sponsor.
Surely.
Two more weeks, guys.
But, but yeah, I had a, um, because, like, I literally don't
even remember what last day to play even gave us.
Oh, Wolverine!
That was it.
I remember now.
the last because like the last day of play was so last
minute because like remember like they were like they
announced a day before like it was supposed to broadcast and
everyone was so confused they were like what the fuck like
like that's like such an awkward time for a stay to play and
then and then like and then literally the only thing that
was good about it was the wolverine game and then they're
like we need filler games right now some trailers, so make
it look like it's not for Wolverine.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's why I remember now.
It was literally just for Wolverine, and that was it.
And then they threw in some filler trailers to make it seem
like it wasn't just for Wolverine.
Because there was literally nothing else to announce.
Yeah.
Well, my original plan.
Originally, my plan was to do two sponsors today but they
all start at 9 p.m so I guess I'll see you guys tonight at 7
p.m I'll see you guys at 7 p.m on the YouTube channel chat
um where we're gonna be doing part five of God of War I
don't know how much progress we're gonna make just a tiny
bit of miscalculation um I don't know because would
originally, if I didn't have another stream tonight, I would
have done a longer stream do more, play something else on
Twitch, but because 7 p.m.
PST.
I always work at PST time.
West Coast, Besh Coast.
But like I don't want to use up all my energy for tonight
because we really have to make progress on God of War.
I don't want, we are not repeating the God of War in this
incident where it took me more than the, I don't I think,
like, it took me eight months to complete God of War.
Like, yeah, it took me eight months to even beat the first
God of War game.
So, we gotta, we gotta step on it, guys.
Like, we're already at one month.
Wait, not even one month.
We started, I think we started God of War 2 almost two
months ago, guys.
We started it in December, chat.
So, we gotta, guys, we're losing time here.
of war game um because we're only at 50 we're only done uh
we're only at the 50 mark so i want to keep my energy to
make more progress tonight yeah sorry we literally started
latin december so it's already mid february so progress is
not great yeah maybe by the time i finish god of war 2 we'll
make it to the trilogy uh oh plans for next week i really
want to play mugenics um some of the games i'm definitely
gonna look for it look um locked down for next week will be
mugenics and that and more god of war mugenics and more god
of war um other than that i don't have anything else really
uh planned for next week other than that i want to make next
week more chill because the last two weeks oh yeah and the
pubg tournament um the pubg uh blind spot tournament that's
happening on saturday uh sorry sunday and monday so yeah
sunday monday and a tuesday will most likely be a rest day
because they really have a lot of time to rest and then
member stream somewhere along the line eugenics and then god
of war we'll see how that goes um anyway guys other than
that if you are new here uh please check me out on youtube
uh that's where our next stream is gonna be in four five six
seven four hours um we're doing more god of war uh if you
want to know whenever i stream on Twitch.
Please check me on Twitter because I usually tweet whenever
I'm on Twitch because that's where I do my gorilla streams
or sponsor streams.
What else?
I have a new Watson skin on Apex.
So please check out exclamation point Watson.
It is a free skin.
So all you have to do is just play Apex Legends to unlock my
new Watson skin.
And also we have a collaboration right now with apex legends
on a physical plush merch so it's me as watson yes so please
check out that plushie it is um um it's only up for
pre-orders for uh one month so after that it'll be gone
forever so this is like a special time to get you know the
very first it's apparently the very first creator collab
merch as well so um so please feel free to check out the
plushie uh and uh and maybe It has like a little momento of
this big moment in history, in my history, in this
community.
Another thing, anniversary merch is out right now.
It's also one month pre-order.
So if you want to grab some, a little mini dokey, a travel
size dokey, a dokey coin endorsed by the dokey bank, or any
other merchandise there, check out the anniversary merch.
What else?
Also, John, thank you for giving your tier one sub for
Tempo.
Thank you.
And my new song.
I released a new cover song.
Girlfriend from Avril Levine.
And I did say it hit 800K views.
I will work on Skaterboy.
So yeah, please feel free to check out my new song, my new
music video.
Everyone worked incredibly hard on it.
I think that's everything.
Anyway, guys.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, pause, check it out.
But move around to get that blood flowing.
Except for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.